why to tie up our asses makes it faster
in the water musics my boobs yeah not
here here check is painful needle mark
God come on post a mass they watch you
just look at my boobs
I was not my intention I didn't you like
them right now now I did because we were
talking about testing Oh failed oh my
god okay you just never really heard a
guy sing that song but it was really
good thank you
by the way let me shower in here we can
huh I don't mean to interrupt but every
one of the beasts is talking about you
guys
thank you well I just wanted to invite
all of you to the country look I know
that the club's kind of fancy and
probably not your scene but you're
scanning thank you what oh you okay
yeah hey chef new kids on the block here
is from Iowa really let me ask you this
a lot of oceans in Iowa no just ponds
and lakes and cocky pretty boys image
what happened to that last pretty boy
recruit we have he died what is this
lifeguard hazing I met Brody told the
world record the 200-meter hey Brody
that Brody yes absolutely we still don't
get
[Music]
let's run instead of Baywatch here we go
[Applause]
you
you
a traditional timeout to have my boy
Chris Jordan will NZ Rihanna girl from
[ __ ] it around pull
hold on the open up
you
and other stuff computer terminal all
we plan
yeah
you
everybody's everyday someone for you
change
you
yeah jack
this straight gold yesterday I feel like
a play about it at all
Oh
[Music]
you never forget the one who steals your
heart or the one Oh
who kicks your ass someday see [ __ ] is
happening in our Beach and my balls say
we need to go over there and check it
out
bad idea Mitch we're lifeguards my bald
a she's thinking he's right
well my balls are saying [ __ ] that noise
let's go handle business your balls are
bullies they watch work because we
follow rules
all better
this guy's a train wreck
on that Brody and not a single [ __ ] was
given it what a bet formers in the whole
world would like if a human [ __ ] a
jetty which is impossible to be so cool
don't be messing with me
there's your cup don't jack off on my
sheet just remember I'm always watching
[Music]
know how to do that
[Music]
hello
[Music]
Oh No
All Things Considered being sorted out a
lot worse
boy that's good luck pick it up we need
to search the morgue for evidence check
came for you to March you want me to
check his paint lift his [ __ ] scrotum
and check his taint - taint man it ain't
even look get closer oh oh mai gerd oh
there's a hole that's just his bottle
smile most of that do not post that it's
a head full of ball sack he turned its
nails into the goddamn X game that's
because we were in lifeguard pursuit
okay
puppet except when there's no [ __ ]
such thing as lifeguard pursuit
[Music]
oh just
welcome to Baywatch just here for the
qualifiers one direction when is this
late guard hazing you stick you turned
the canals into the next game we were in
lifeguard pursuit oh okay
except there's no such thing as
lifeguard pursuit vision
emotion
you